[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new venom - spider-man in
Morbius video Sony just blew up their
movies schedule and is causing a bunch
of changes to the way spider-man is
crossing over into the venom movies so
we got some footage to break down I'll
talk about what's going on with
spider-man in the Sony movies that's
venom - and Morbius right now if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're doing an
Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave all
your theories about spider-man inside
venom - in the Morbius movie so we'll
start with the big announcements first
then I'll talk about the spider-man
venom - in Morbius footage everyone
queue up the Daily Bugle to see how Jay
jonah Jameson is going to blame
spider-man for all this virus in the
movie delays but going down the list
starting with number 5 if he didn't see
the big announcement yesterday it was
right at the end of the day Sony finally
caved to the virus and canceled all the
release dates for the movies that were
supposed to come out this summer
not just the Morbius movie but most
people just saw that and said oh what's
gonna happen now thankfully Sony
included some more details about what is
actually planning on doing next
so Morbius is supposed to come out March
19 20 21 pretty big change originally
everyone thought that Morbius would be
safe from the blowback because it wasn't
coming out till right after Comic Con at
the end of July
late summer should be fine people will
be going to movies by then seems like
Sony is a little bit worried about that
maybe people will not be going to see
movies in July they've also delayed the
release date of their special untitled
mystery spider-man movie that was coming
out next October as well we still don't
know what that is officially but it's
going to be another big spider-man
spin-off movies set within the venom
universe number 4 here's the thing
though you hear Sony is moving all the
release dates for its summer movies and
you remember venom 2 is also coming out
just a little while after that later
this year and you start to panic wait a
minute what's gonna happen to venom 2
within that announcement that Sony made
though they claimed venom 2 would still
come out in October later this year
despite the fact that they're actually
closer to finishing the Morbius movie
they've been working on Morbius way
longer than they were working on venom 2
so that's great that they're not
delaying venom 2 something to look
forward to later this year we're just
gonna need you to prove it and release
that venom 2 trailer that you promised
us earlier but if
Sony and Marvel are working together to
set up Tom Hollands spider-man crossover
with all the Sony venom movies and their
spin-offs like Morbius is a spin-off of
the venom movie and then the sinister
six teams set up that they're doing it
all that's supposed to start in the
Morbius movie as we saw from all those
spider-man Easter eggs in the Morbius
trailer then continue on with even
bigger Easter eggs and crossover during
venom two number three why would they
choose to release Morbius next year
after venom two instead of just
releasing Morbius in October and moving
venom 2 to early next year it'd be kind
of like Marvel releasing Avengers end
game before Avengers infinity war just
really weird like you're missing all the
setup stuff before you do full-blown
crossover stuff
well according to all the news reports
that the Hollywood trades were filing
last night after the big Sony
announcement about the spider-man movie
changes the real reasons so need to laid
the Morbius movie isn't because it's
afraid no one's gonna go to theaters in
July they claim that Sony is actually
trying to hedge their bets for early
2021 and fill a big hole in their
release schedule for that early part of
the year because what you don't realize
is is that the problem Sony and a lot of
other movie studios including Marvel
have is that they were supposed to be
filming movies right now like Sony was
supposed to be filming Tom Hollands
uncharted movie if you ever thought that
movie would happen the Uncharted movie
was originally supposed to come out in
March next year but last month when the
virus blew up Hollywood and everyone had
to stop filming movies and TV shows all
over the world all the movies that were
supposed to come out early next year
have now been delayed to later in next
year so even though Sony could have just
pushed Morbius to later this year they
just needed a really big movie to
release early next year and they're
spider-man venom spin-off movies have
just been earning them dumptrucks of
cash even if you didn't like the venom
movie it earned a giant pile of cash
this is also something that's affecting
Marvel with their movies right now - in
the MCU but I'll do a separate Marvel
video because they made a bunch of
different changes but number two we have
a situation now where all the Spiderman
Morbius stuff is supposed to set up
venom to Spider Man crossover isn't
happening in the right order
what were those scenes going to look
like and what was the story going to be
and how are they going to fix it so that
it all makes sense in the timeline when
we see it in the right order
so first thing Tom Holland wasn't
supposed to have a full-blown cameo seen
during Morbius after her test screenings
recently it was just reported that
during the Morbius movie this vulture
scene with Michael Keaton's vulture from
spider-man homecoming was happening at
the same prison that carnage was being
held at at the end of the first venom
movie supposedly that vulture cameo
scene implied that Cletus Kasady had not
yet gotten the carnage symbiote it was
still just Cletus Kasady chilling out in
prison but the Morbius character was
supposed to have been captured by
tyreese's character in the FBI thrown in
that same prison then eventually break
out using his new abilities and during
that is when you see the vulture cameo
they just used that opportunity to also
break out of prison where they would
start setting up the sinister six
because the scorpion was also supposed
to show up during that or at least be
referenced in some way we're putting a
squad together let's go do some crime
during that big prison bust out you were
supposed to see some sort of Cletus
Kasady breakout that would then lead
into the venom 2 movie explaining how he
got out of prison but that was supposed
to be the end of the vulture sinister
six scenes just really quick set up for
future sinister six stuff I'm sure they
paid Michael Keaton millions and
millions of dollars for his two minutes
of screen time that Spider Man seen from
the Morbius trailer we all saw wasn't
supposed to happen till later in the
movie but Morbius literally just walks
past the graffiti in an alleyway in
that's it
the suit was supposed to have been
changed to Tom Hollands new spider-man
far from home suit by the time the movie
came out so that it all made sense
the murderer graffiti would be on top of
his far from home suit referencing the
end of spider-man far from home in
Mysterio's death we don't have as much
information about what spider-man scenes
during venom two are supposed to look
like other than Sony was just trying to
get Tom Haun to sign a new deal to have
a full-blown cameo scene but being
realistic I think that was just supposed
to be a quick 10-second cameo scene
showing him on the run John wick three
style spider-man worked from home before
the big outbreak the memes were all
about spider-man being homeless can't go
home spider-man hunted now it's all
about him being trapped inside his home
I'm gonna nominate a bunch of people so
we've got Chris Hemsworth Chris Pryor
our DJ the Russo brothers Karen Gillan
elizabeth Olsen Mark Ruffalo Dave
Bautista Chadwick Boseman
the rock Bryan Reynolds Jake Gyllenhaal
Hugh Jackman
cannot like this video all right we got
the temper shots got one two three four
five six seven eight
no all right they've been a couple big
spider-man three announcements in the
past day two so I will do a new
spider-man three video at some point big
couple of years for spider-man coming up
with all the different movies that he's
appearing in but number one WTF now that
the order of all these cameo scenes and
Easter eggs have been changed what Sony
has to do now is change the venom to
Spider Man cameo little so that it
doesn't reference too much stuff from
the Morbius movie that you would have
had to have seen in order for it all to
make sense like just have Spider Man
cameo at the end of the venom movie
implying that there's going to be a
spider-man venom crossover in a future
movie think about the way Sony
engineered that Morbius trailer with
that weird Tobey Maguire spider-man suit
referencing spider-man far from home it
didn't totally make sense like fans were
thinking multiverse crazy Tobey Maguire
Easter eggs but apparently the reason
why the Tobey Maguire suit was in there
was just because Sony wanted to slap
something in really quickly and wasn't
thinking too much about the continuity
or the larger implications so they're
not thinking too much about that making
sense they're probably not too worried
about the venom to Morbius cameo scenes
happening in the wrong order in it not
making sense either that's okay that's
what YouTube's breakdown videos are for
the really easy fix that they can have
though is just change some of their j'
jonah Jameson cameo scenes so that when
he's yelling about spider-man in the
background in the Morbius movie in in
venom - they just have him referencing
spider-man venom and Morbius in the
timeline so that it all makes sense
together we don't know a lot about
what's happening with Jay jonah Jameson
during venom - only that he's supposed
to cameo during Morbius and venom - and
just yell about spider-man in the
background pretty much the same way that
the spider-man ps4 game used that
character in better news there are a lot
of reports about Sony releasing a bigger
venom two trailers sometime really
really soon if they wind up doing that
of course I'll do a video for it as long
as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see that video when I
post it the main reason why Sony didn't
delay venom two is because it's coming
out later in October after they think
people will be seeing movies again in
they expect venom 2 to be a much bigger
box officer than the Morbius movie but
everyone let me know in the comments how
do you think that Sony is going to
change all the spider-man stuff in the
Morbius movie in venom 2 so that it all
makes sense if they release venom 2
before the Morbius movie while I was
making this video there were also a
bunch of announcements about spider-man
3 in the other Marvel movies so I'll try
to make that video as soon as possible
but leave all your requests and big
questions in the comments below I'll
name a new giveaway winner when I post
my next big Marvel video everyone click
here for my breakdown of that new Marvel
Eternals footage and click here for my
breakdown of the new marvel Weapon X
scenes thank you so much for watching
everyone stays safe I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]